news session and
let's get started our first talk is uh
um from ashley akaravar from uc berkeley
hi everyone thank you for
attending um and first i just like to
thank the organizers for inviting me and
also the simons institute for giving a
wonderful fellowship for this semester
um the title of my talk is causal
influence for social and engineering
systems
so before i go into the specifics i just
want to give you a broad idea of the
type of things i think about
so my work is really about bridging two
fields causal inference and econometrics
which thinks very carefully about how do
you do causal reasoning despite
unmeasured compounding
and connecting that the variety of
interesting frameworks have come out of
it for example instrumental variables
regression discontinuities difference in
differences and generally trying to find
and analyze natural experiments that are
happening around us
but in general the estimators that come
out of econometrics are designed for
small economic data sets so that's
changing
and trying to bridge that with with
machine learning thinks about prediction
with modern data sets right data sets
for the high dimensional noisy sparse a
variety of interesting frameworks such
as kernel methods neural networks high
dimensional regression have come out to
deal with that but they generally are
not designed to handle confounding
and so my aim is to bridge these two
fields we can get the best of both
worlds
specifically my thesis has been about
bridging two subfields one is called
synthetic controls which asks the
question of what if an intervention
didn't occur it's a core id and an
econometrics
i try to bridge that with matrix
intensive completion so the core idea in
eecs stats in ml it's about imputing
missing data and a matrix for a tensor
my thesis is about two pieces of the
work the first is synthetic
interventions which brings heavier some
tensor completion two synthetic controls
the joint worked with the varchar as my
advisor at mit and denis shen who is a
long time collaborator and a postdoc
here with uh with bin and
peng and jas i don't think i see him in
the audience
and the second piece of work is causal
matrix completion which brings ideas
from synthetic controls to matrix
completion
today i'm just going to talk about the
first piece of work for synthetic
interventions
so the motivating application for the
remaining of this talk is going to be
some work we did with an alzheimer's
therapeutics company okay so they gave
us access to the phase three clinical
trial data the 1162 patients in that
trial they're testing the efficacy of
three different therapies
plus placebos let's put up four
therapies and what we're measuring is
something called the alloskog score this
is the alzheimer's disease assessment
scale cognitive subscale right and
that's a measure of cognitive ability
and the change in that is what the fda
cares about when they try to change when
they decide to approve or disprove a
drug okay this study around for two
years
the reason we work with them is that at
the end of the two years they actually
found that the average treatment effect
of all three therapies was insignificant
and this is a big problem for them the
cost of trial that they ran was more
than half a billion dollars the cost of
recruiting just one patient range
anywhere between 5k to 100k usd and not
to mention the ethical concerns of
testing on human subjects
the question we set out to answer with
them was that maybe there was a
subpopulation for which therapies were
effective
towards that we wanted to ask a
relatively ambitious question which is
that can we estimate the atheroscope
score for each patient under each
therapy
this is the question i'm going to show
you how you can pose this question just
simply pose this question as one of
tensor completion
the key object to study in causal
inference is potential outcomes so now
setting potential outcomes will be
indexed by n t and d
so y and d refers to what if
patient n on visit t had been assigned
therapy d
one way of thinking about this at least
visually is through a tensor
so rows here correspond to different
patients
colons correspond to different visits
and the third axis correspond to
different therapies
so say there's some patient alice
the first point here would be alice's
alice spoke score
on visit t under no intervention
the second point would be alice's alice
coke score and visit t under therapy one
and so on and so forth
if you had access to this entire tensor
of potential outcomes you'd be done
right you could answer the question of
what would happen to each patient under
each therapy
but that's not how your data actually
looks like this is the data we actually
had from the company
okay so there was a six month period
before the rc began with the collecting
baseline information about each of these
patients
so that's the first six months
so there we actually had data of all the
patients under no intervention
but as a result we had no data of any of
the outcomes under therapy one two or
three but that's the part and white
that's missing
and once the rc began for example the
patients got therapy three we observed
them on the therapy three but we don't
observe them under new intervention
therapy one and therapy two
right and this really encodes the
fundamental challenge of causal
inference is that you only observe one
outcome but you want to know all
potential outcomes
so given this kind of sparsity pattern
what is an rct estimates at least the
naive estimator from rct tells you the
average treatment effect right looks at
the average outcome so everyone got
therapy one minus the average outcome
everyone got no therapy or no
intervention right
so why are they so beloved rcts why they
use all the clinical trials it's because
there's explicit randomization right so
there's no unmeasured compounding
but what can rc not estimate it can't
estimate for example the individual
treatment effect for example what
happens to alice under therapy one minus
alice in a new intervention why because
obviously you can only observe alice
under one intervention
so this is kind of the limitation of
icts is that what might work best on
average may not work best for each
individual
right so there's randomization but
there's no personalization
so let's go back to the question of
estimating the other stock score for
each patient under each therapy let me
show you that this is simply a question
of tensor completion why for example
say ask the what if question of what if
the no intervention subjects received
therapy two
that really amounts to the shaded green
part of the tense on the right hand side
that's all it is
there's no coincidence and so elegantly
encode this problem through tensor
completion for those of you who are in
the causal entrance literature we all
say that well causal infants are the
missing data problem and for those of us
who come from ml say well tensor
completion is a missing data problem
so they're really asking the same
questions just with a different language
for example the notion of different
experimental observational studies that
really amounts to different sparsity
patterns in the induced tensor
the goal of causal inference which is
estimating kind of actual potential
outcomes that really amounts to imputing
specific missing entries in this induced
tensor
and this problem that
pervades or plagues causal intensive
confounding you can really encode that
as this missing not at random data and
i'll make this formal as we go along
but the key conceptual contribution is
that you can encode a lot of interesting
problems and causal inference as one of
tensor completion
okay so this is the question
this is the the tensor completion
perspective in it where you're trying to
fill out the right hand side of the
sensor the shaded part here
all right i'm going to show you now one
algorithm to do that called synthetic
interventions
so suppose the two people bob and alice
okay suppose bob received therapy one
after the rsd began it was under no
intervention fire
and suppose alice who continued to
remain under no intervention once the rc
began
so what are the counterfactual questions
of interest for bob i'd like to know
what if bob remained under no
intervention or instead he received
therapy two or three
and the one of questions of interest for
alice is what if alice received therapy
one two or three okay
so let's focus on one of these questions
which is what if bob remained unknown to
mention one of these six questions
that question has been tackled by
synthetic controls i think abby gave a
wonderful introduction yesterday so be a
bit quick
so
suppose i want to ask the question of
what if bob remained in no intervention
what you do is look at the
pre-intervention outcomes of all the
patients who will continue to be no
intervention once the rc begins okay i'm
going to call that matrix of outcomes
why don't this pre
i'm going to call the vector of outcomes
for bob
y pre
what you do what our body and his
co-authors propose
is that you write y pre is a convex
combination of y donor spree
the second step you look at the
post-intervention outcomes of the units
that remain under control
call the wide donors post you apply the
beta hat that you got to get a synthetic
trajectory of bob okay so it's just a
beautiful simple two-step algorithm
you can repeat this process and fill out
the first slice of this tensor right
every patient got treated i can come up
with the counterfactual what would
happen to them had they remained
untreated
but what synthetic controls can't answer
for you is for example what did alice
got therapy so all the parts of this
tensor that i have a question mark on
top of it that cannot be answered by
synthetic controls
indeed abadi himself says in his
2020 review paper in jel he says results
in estimation with multiple that is in
the presence of intervention are absent
in the literature
and why is this problem not symmetric
synthetic inventions to synthetic
controls it's an asymmetry and data
availability
right in the pre-intervention period we
have data available under no
intervention
we have no data available under therapy
right so the asymmetry in the
missingness pattern between the slice of
the tensor is what makes this problem
harder
so
synthetic controls
before i tell you the about synthetic
inventions let me tell you a little bit
more about synthetic controls it's
actually caught in
a lot of um popularity within healthcare
itself this notion of synthetic control
arms are now being used for example by
pfizer by merck by metadata flatiron
health is a company that specializes in
building these synthetic control arms um
for oncology
and the fda is getting more okay with
using these kinds of techniques because
keeping people on placebo is essentially
a death warrant
right there is more open to statistical
techniques
what it can't answer for example is what
if alice got therapy one two or three
which is necessary for the taurex case
study
synthetic controls didn't really start
from um healthcare started from
policymaking and policy evaluation which
is still probably the place that's most
popular and the variety of really
interesting things that have come out
policy questions that have been analyzed
using that for example tax legislation
police reform even brexit
and i want to repeat the same thing we
said yesterday
of what athen limits said which is one
of the most important innovations in the
policy
evaluation literature in the last 15
years and i must say i agree alberto is
my advisor and i found this framework of
synthetic controls to be just absolutely
beautiful
and i've dedicated many years of my life
to thinking about it because i just
think of it as such a flexible and
elegant framework to think about so many
problems
but as alberto says himself is that the
results in estimation with multiple
interventions absent right
so what i hope to convince you through
this slide is that the significant
impact of impact of estimating
counterfactuals in the presence of
interventions
so okay so now i'm going to tell you the
answer of how would you estimate what
happens to alice under therapy one
actually once you look at it from this
tensor perspective the answer kind of
pops out quite easily
what you do is you look at all the
patients who are going to get therapy
one look at they are pre-intervention
outcomes otherwise doing this three you
look at the pre-dimension outcomes of
alice it's called the y free now you
build a linear model between y pre and y
donor spree but the way you do this is
through a regularized linear regression
called principal component regression
which is where you first do pca and why
donorspring
then once you take that model learn beta
hat you apply that to the post-invention
outcomes of the units under therapy one
okay now you actually look at the post
rc data we apply the beta hat to get a
synthetic trajectory of alice under
therapy one
i know here we're using nothing but the
other stock score because that's all we
had access to right no additional
coverage has been used
suppose i want to know what happens to
alice in the therapy too you do is the
same thing except now you change the
donor group now you regress it based on
the outcomes of the patients who are
going to receive therapy too
you can repeat this process for example
what happens alice in therapy three look
at the prevention outcomes of the people
who got therapy three and so and so
forth given this you can fill out the
entire right-hand side of this tensor
right by iterating between every patient
and treatment
i know that no additional data over the
additional rct is being used no
additional experiment is being run
okay so just that we're on the same page
what are some of the key differences
between synthetic controls as it stands
and synthetic inventions
the first one probably the most
interesting one is is where the model is
applied in synthetic controls you learn
a model under control you make
predictions under control
in synthetic interventions you learn a
modern control but you make predictions
under intervention
this begs the question of when can a
linear model be transferred across
interventions i believe this might have
some interesting applications for things
such as transfer learning learning
distribution shift causal
transportability what have you and these
aspects i'm very excited to explore so
happy to chat with anyone if they want
to
and the second key difference is how the
model is learned what's the statistical
procedure so classically at least we use
convex regression
but given despite that synthetic
controls has gotten a whole life of its
own in the last five years and it's been
used everywhere the theoretical basis of
it is catching up
in some sense so lots of interesting
questions that need to be answered for
example
why a convex model when is that
motivated what's the causal framework
finite sample guarantees valid
confidence intervals there's been a lot
of work in the last 15 years or sorry
last five years trying to tackle this
question work that's being done here at
berkeley for example but our venus
collaborators um with athene invince and
wager and their collaborators at
stanford uh abadi and china zhukov at
mit and so on so forth right so there's
really been a flurry activity
and at least for the framework that we
propose and the type of estimate type of
causal parameters that we're interested
in it turns out that pcr is crucial to
proving our hormonal circulation we'll
talk about why
so before i go to the theory let me show
you a validation exercise we ran with
the top with the
data
so there were 976 patients of data we
held out so for example in people who
got therapy one
there were 159 of those patients
we
held out the data of 109 of them that is
we held out their data once the rc began
and only looked at their pre-rc baseline
data
and the question was could we recreate
the outcomes in the post-intervention
period
once using only their pre-intervention
outcomes
so in blue here is a true distribution
of these patients what i'm plotting here
is the change in the atherosclerosis
core preverses post rct that's what the
fda care is about
and what you want is the yellow is
what's being produced by synthetic
interventions
so what you want is the blue and the
yellow to be on top of each other at
least that's visually what you see i'll
quantify that in a second
repeated this process for therapy two
and therapy three where there we held up
the data 124 patients and 743 patients
and again you can see the blue and
yellow are relatively close to each
other
to quantify this one way you can do that
is through the jensen-shannon metric
which is a way of defining the distances
between distributions the closer it is
to zero the better so zero means you
could identify you could perfectly
recreate it one means you're maximally
different so at least you can see that
the answers are the the difference is
close to zero
natural baseline to compare with is what
would the distribution look like if you
use the 50 patients
right you can see it's significantly
worse
right so there is a lot of information
gained by using synthetic interventions
over this natural baseline
the way we actually created these
distributions is by creating the in by
plotting the in predicting the
individual trajectories of each patient
so here i'm just doing a simple
validation exercise where we randomly
took data of three patients from three
different therapies so in therapy one
patient x so blue is the true atoscox
core
yellow is what we predicted and then the
shaded part is the confidence interval
that we produce we'll tell you how we
did that we repeat the process for
therapies uh two and three
yeah oh um is this like
so this one i'm looking at the
the densities that we have here this is
like
somehow an aggregate this is not saying
that
i predicted you well it's saying i
predicted this aggregate the
distribution of intensity well not even
like the l2 norm but it's a different
kind of thing is that is that right or
is that not
so you're currently right the other
natural thing with the plot for example
is the average mean squared error or the
medium means whatever and it's also very
small this one i showed it because this
is what they actually care about in
terms of this is what convinced them
that something good was happening so
that's very true
also it's visually a bit prettier it is
yeah
itself shouldn't that
equalize those contributions
um why would it
because it randomized so that means that
the distribution of potential outcomes
but they're going through different
therapies right
so their outcomes will change because of
therapy because of the interventions
and so this is a part of what we're
doing with the company so what do we
actually find with that
um
what we found is that if 20 of the
patients are actually potentially
responsive if you look at the synthetic
trajectory of them under therapy one
minus a placebo there was a significant
gap
and now what we're doing is looking for
predictive biomarkers so how do you go
from these potential outcomes to a
detailed causal mechanism say for
example a mechanism from the genetics to
these potential outcomes that's how to
do that in a principled way something
i'm very interested in working on maybe
people here would have expertise on them
i think the reason that this company has
been very excited is that we can
potentially save millions of dollars and
also unnecessary human testing
and we've jointly filed a patent with
them
and again i know that we've used no
additional experiments to run this only
data from the original rct
is that accounting for multiple testing
or is it just individually just you see
what's kind of significant
all we did here is a simple thing but i
looked at the trajectory of each patient
i looked at their synthetic trajectory i
looked at their uh synthetic detector
and therapy one minus receposity
and if the gap between the the two
participants was large enough it was
like bigger than twenty that's only
character so i said that was potentially
secret potentially responsible
how many patients
they were a thousand wonders
and you're defining statistical
significance
exactly
and
i wouldn't have time to get into this
but we use this account of writing about
the application so we've been currently
consulting with with uber done some work
on cover 19 with the poverty action lab
at mit we don't have time to get into it
but the point is that all these
questions we could pose them as one of a
tensor completion and they kind of
impose different kinds of fastly
patterns and then use tensor once you
model it correctly and what synthetic
inventions does is just help you impute
it that's it
so now kind of get on the theory which
is when and why the synthetic
interventions work what's the causal
framework and what kind of statistical
guarantees can you produce
so two essential questions to me are one
when can a linear model be transferred
between different interventions
the second one is what kind of
confounding is allowed in the
observational setting
the first assumption is what i call a
tensor factor model so in in general in
in synthetic controls
the general framework you require then
what structure you require is that that
matrix that first slice of that tensor
the new interventions is low rank that
is the low dimensional unit factor and a
lower dimensional latent time factor
that gives you that matrix
that's really what lets you share
information across units in time
but now if you want to share information
across interventions as well then you
need that tensor to be low rank so here
r refers to the cp rank of this tensor
the canonical or the basic rank okay so
now we have a latent factorization
across interventions as well
this is what we require on the expected
potential outcomes we model the actual
potential outcomes as random so the
epsilon ntd is a mean zero subgaussian
that models the randomness in the
potential
and these latent factors
for example just to give some intuition
could be for example patient genetics
how the atherosclerosis code progresses
over two weeks the chemical pathway used
etc and this might generally be might
genuinely be latent may not be
observable for any uh observed outcome
the second assumption we make is linear
standard inclusion so suppose i want to
produce counterfactuals for unit n under
intervention d
what it requires of the latent unit
factor of unit n lies in the linear span
of the latent factors for units who of
the units that got intervention d
and if you sample the unit the latent
factors independently you can actually
show this holes with high probability
and so what are these two assumptions
value of the tensor factor model and the
linear span inclusion what they buy you
is that this implies and exists there
exists an invariant linear model that
holds across time and interventions
so this is really what motivates these
two assumptions is really what motivates
learning a linear model and transferring
it
the third assumption is about what kind
of confounding is allowed in the
observational setting so observational
data meaning can be confounded what that
means is potential outcomes are not
independent of treatment assignment
which is being denoted by script a here
right in an rct by design we have
potential outcomes independent of
treatment design
what does that mean in the language of
of tensors so the sparsity pattern is
induced by the treatment assignment
right that is not independent of the
entries of the tensor which are the
potential argument that's what i mean by
missing not at random
versus
in an rct this positive pattern is
independent of the entries of the tensor
so the question is what kind of
confounding is allowed in synthetic
interventions under what conditions are
your potential outcomes independent of
treatment assignment
the type of assumption you require is
called selection relating factors so the
latent factors here are the collection
of latent factors per unit time and
intervention that's being given by
script lf
conditional on them the potential
outcomes and vapor assignments become
independent so this could be thought of
as maybe analogous to the classic
selection observables where now on the
right hand side it would be observed
covariates rather than latent factors
and this is the type of assumptions
that's also been made
earlier to us by uh atheidal in their
2018 paper and by kalos at all i believe
in 2019
so another way of interpreting is is
that the latent factors define the
expected potential outcomes so treatment
assignment can only be a function of
expected potential outcomes not observed
outcomes so this will allow for example
adaptive treatment assignment so if you
look at previous outcomes saw them and
then decided through an assignment this
identification argument would break down
here's a graphical way of looking at it
here the lf are your latent factors they
point to both the treatment assignment
and the potential outcomes in that sense
the latent factors can be unmeasured
confounders
the condition on them the epsilons don't
have a direct arrow to the assignments
so that's the exogenous you need
the fourth assumption is not really
required for identification but it's
needed for
for statistical estimation
to subspace inclusion that is
the column space of the column span of
the expected pre-intervention matrix
needs to contain the column span of the
expected post and dimension matrix
and this is really a purely linear
algebraic condition for generalization
we're not assuming for example that your
data sample iid because that wouldn't
really make sense because the data you
sample on the one intervention is
clearly going to come from a different
distribution from a different
intervention what you really require is
that your pre-intervention outcomes are
sufficiently rich
what that means is the column scan is
large enough to learn something that
and this i believe there's some
interesting applications to for example
transfer learning distribution free
learning et cetera and given how
important it is we provide a formal
hypothesis test to check for this
okay so putting it all together when
does synthetic interventions work we did
a bunch of hard work it's these four
assumptions okay the lowering tensor
factor model the linear span inclusion
selection labeling factors and subspace
inclusion so low-rank tensor factor
model you can test for by plotting the
mean plotting matrices that are induced
by your tensor
and if it is high rank and you look at
the if you look at svd then you should
not be using synthetic interventions
it's at least a diagnostic where not to
use it
the linear span inclusion you can look
at the pre-treatment fit except we can
hold out a little bit of the
pre-treatment data and see how well you
can fit it if it doesn't fit well that
means linear span inclusion is not
holding then don't use it
including you provide a formal
hypothesis test the selection relating
factors are somewhat philosophical point
um it holds for free obviously in rct
i think what it really precludes you
from is adaptive assignment of treatment
that's really when it breaks down
so what kind of theoretical results can
you show under these four assumptions
the first is parameter estimation
that is the beta hat you learn from pcr
consistently estimates a star that's
induced by the second assumption
in the large in the high dimensional
case there can be many beta stars that
are observation equivalent what pcr is
picking out is the minimum two norm one
which is unique
and that sense pcr implicitly
regularizes
your r refers to the rank of the
expected pre-intervention matrix
t naught is number of pre-intervention
periods and nd is the number of units
that got assigned in dimension d
the second you can show is finite sample
consistency that is the counter factual
trajectory that's predicted by synthetic
inventions that consistently estimates
the expected contractual trajectory for
a given unit and intervention
and here t1 is the number of
post-intervention periods
and thirdly if you assume additional
uh assumptions on the scaling of t
naught t one and d you can prove that
the estimated asymptotically normally
distributed on the expected kind of
factorial
the tensor rank of the factor model
really shows up in terms of making the
linear span inclusion and the selection
related factors more believable that's
low ranking these two assumptions are
more
likely to hold but the rank of the
tensor doesn't directly show up in the
balance
it only shows up in terms of the rank of
the
uh premium dimension donor matrix which
is bounded by the tensorflow obviously
but the red
what do you mean by this it doesn't
change with your simple size of the pre
or the post-directional period we
especially give the bound in terms of r
right so it can scale in some sense like
if you if this as long as the numerator
is a lot smaller than the word it's
allowed to grow in that sense
and so just to interpret that's a lot of
that right here what does that really
mean
so what it means to me at least is that
if you have n patients in d therapies i
want to estimate those outcomes of all n
patients under all d therapies to
accuracy within delta
say hypothetically would create d twins
of each patient
the number of samples you would need to
be able to do that is n times d times
one over delta square
with synthetic interventions under those
four assumptions what you get is n times
one over delta to the four
okay so crucially you've lost the
dependence on d
which is great because especially as you
move towards say personalized therapies
d is going to start growing
what you've lost though is your
dependence on delta sub optimal now
like an interesting open question is
what's the best achievable sample
complexity for these kinds of [ __ ]
patterns intensity
i believe a natural lower bound is n
times one over delta square the question
is can we come up with an algorithm and
or an analysis that hits that
okay i'm going to end in another minute
let's just spend a little bit of time
telling you about principle component
regression
that's the key to
our
our entire procedure
so again what is pcr is where you first
do pc and y donors pre to find a low
rank approximation before doing
ordinarily squares
so why pcr one it has a bunch of
implicit benefits the first is that it
enforces spectral sparsity and your
pre-interview why don't the spree and in
the high dimensional setting where the
number of measurements might be a lot
larger the number of feet might be a lot
smaller than the number of features this
helps
the second one is that it implicitly
denoises why donuts
okay so this helps you deal with the
problem of error and variables which is
the challenging problem in statistics
where you can think of why donors pre as
a noisy observation of the expected wide
donor spree matrix which is what you'd
actually like to regress against
i just note that aaron variables has
many interesting applications
measurement error is classical in stats
but also for example differential
privacy where you actually artificially
inject noise into your system like
laplacian noise to make it
differentiably private you can pose that
as a problem of error and variables
regression
so the key assumption we make is that
the expected pre-intervention matrix is
approximately low rank
what we do not assume though is a
restricted eigenvalue condition on the
pre-intervention expected matrix which
is required for sale asso based
approaches to higher dimensional
regression
and the key intuition geometrically
what's happening is that your lower rank
signal is spectrally
concentrated versus by random matrix
there we know that noise is especially
diffused and that that is really what
pcr is exploiting for these low right
factor multiples
so we do is improve the final sample c
of pcr for parameter estimation and test
data
and this is the first test error result
for error in variables regression plus
in a high dimensional fixed design
setting
and this is really crucial for us to
prove cisco guarantees for synthetic
interventions and to formally analyze
synthetic controls itself
and um
with that i'd like to so maybe i'll just
give a quick summary is that
what we did is we addressed the end
result problem of counterfactuals in the
presence of interventions and this
provided novel results for synthetic
controls and this has been currently
used at tarex and uber to guide their
decision making
and in doing so we deal with the problem
of error and variable regression and we
found that pcr is the right algorithm to
do so we provide the first
generalization error result for error in
variables regression
thank you very much
um due to time limit we will save all
the questions to the panel discussion
and our next speaker is
emma perkovic from university washington